so this is this is very interesting I
want to take a little bit of a break
from serious politics for a second and
not that the alleged rape by Donald
Trump of a thirteen-year-old along with
Jeffrey Epstein is not serious but I
want to just take a step back and show
you just an example of Donald Trump
being the totally triggered snowflake
that we know him to be at one of his own
rallies so as you know just to very
quickly sort of reset Jeffrey Epstein
has now been arrested on really serious
child sex trafficking charges as you
also may know there are longstanding
allegations against Donald Trump and
Epstein for raping the same 13-year old
girl at Epstein's Manhattan New York
City condo years ago Trump recently did
one of his Magga alleys in Duluth
Minnesota
there was a protester in the crowd
holding up a picture of Donald Trump
with Jeffrey Epstein because again they
used to be friends they used to hang out
now I would put the picture on the
screen for you it's a very well-known
picture but the pictures copyright is
held by Getty Images which is one of the
most aggressive bogus copyright
claimants around so I'm not going to do
that but you can easily find the picture
online if you do a google image search
for Donald Trump Jeffrey Epstein Trump
is on the right in the picture Epstein a
two Epstein's left that would be with
his arm around Jeffrey Epstein
so at Trump's Duluth Minnesota rally
this is just great a protester or an
audience member I guess you could call
them had a blown-up version of this
picture and you can see as Donald Trump
is talking he notices it and he does
kind of a double take and then he
clearly recognizes it and that's already
kind of interesting because it means
very clearly the Epstein stuff is on
Trump's mind that Trump from this far
away would instantly recognize what the
picture is of and Trump immediately
starts calling for the guy holding the
picture to be removed he interrupts his
own speech and brilliantly the fox news
feed actually showed the guy holding the
blown-up picture and the content of the
picture itself I was actually thinking
maybe this is what Trump saw over the
weekend on Fox that angered him so much
that he went on that crazy anti fox news
Twitter storm over the weekend in any
case check out our president more than
seven
years old triggered so strongly by a
picture of him with one of his friends
that he interrupts his own speech and
calls even more attention to the guy and
then obviously the 70 plus year old
billionaire president starts insulting
the guy holding the picture with red
meat for the Trump Estonians joking
about the gender identity of the guy
because oh my goodness it's a guy with
long hair which obviously is what we
would make fun of let's take a look at
the video you have to mark up thousands
of miles coming through Mexico you come
up thousands of miles coming through
Mexico and we're gonna stop it
get him out of here get America
[Applause]
go home to your mom darling go home
you get them out of here
out
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
was that a man or a woman because he
needs a haircut more than I do
the chance of USA USA are almost fitting
in a sense USA USA where our president
is accused of rape and sexual assault 15
times still becomes president and then
kicked out of his speeches anybody who
calls attention to his friendly
relationships with his Co acute KOCO
alleged perpetrator I guess we would
call them the crowd chants USA as a
protester is ejected for holding up a
picture of Trump with a man he allegedly
conspired with to rape a
thirteen-year-old we don't have to read
dystopian science fiction of hundreds of
years from now or 50 years from now I
mean this is the dystopia understand
this is how Trump takes back control
with gender identity jokes Trump is
accused of raping a 13 year old with his
friend Jeffrey Epstein Epstein gets
arrested the allegations are horrible
someone in the audience has a picture of
Trump with Epstein and Trump gets the
crowd back on his side instead of being
concerned about the allegations
the crowd is riotous over Trump making
fun of whether it's a boy or a girl
because hey they have long hair and long
hair is for girls and the crowd goes
absolutely bonkers how funny right a boy
with long hair it's like he's a girl in
some way the President of the United
States making fun of men for having long
hair which is extra strange by the way
considering Donald Trump looks just like
his own mother and that's not I mean
it's it's not a joke
Trump looks just like his own mother I'm
not sure if you've seen pictures but who
cares this is what the guy in the Glass
House is choosing to throw stones about
he's accused of raping a child and
someone holds up a picture and this is
how the President behaves the world is
laughing the world is laughing and it is
going to take years if not a decade once
Trump finally is gone to rebuild the
relationships that he has embarassingly
destroyed make sure you're following me
on instagram at David Pakman where you
can ask me questions about this or any
other stories from today's show follow
show on Instagram as well at David
Pakman show